[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء اعلنت وزاره
العدل العراقيه انها قامت باجلاء السجناء
عن سجن ابو غريب قرب بغداد لوجوده في
منطقه ساخنه امنيا وفق تعبير الوزاره
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين اقتراب التوتر الامني من حزام
بغداد واثره على الانتخابات
المرتقبه وهل باتت ولايه الملك الثالثه
امرا مشكوكا
فيه اذا دفعت العمليه العسكريه في الفلوجه
والرمادي غرب العراق دفعت كثيرا من ابناء
العشائر الى توسيع عمليات ضد الجيش حتى
وصلت المناطق المعروفه بحزام العاصمه
بغداد اعلان وزاره العدل العراقيه اجلاء
النزلاء عن سجن ابو غريب الواقع في تلك
المنطقه يعد اشاره اضافيه الى مدى التردي
الذي بلغته الحاله الامنيه في البلاد فكيف
سيؤثر ذلك على الانتخابات
المرتقبه مضطربه او متفجره او مرشحه
للانفجار ما من منطقه في العراق لا يشملها
احد تلك التصنيفات اليوم فالبلاد المتاهب
لموعد انتخابي هام تمر بموجه من اعمال
العنف هي الاسوا منذ سنوات لا تنقطع انباء
الهجمات والتفجيرات الداميه من محافظات
عراقيه عده اما المحافظات الغربيه تحديدا
فلم تفقد شيئا من سخونتها الامنيه على وقع
عمليه عسكريه واسعه النطاق تجاوزت شهرها
الثالث وقد اتسعت رقعه المواجهات في
الاونه الاخيره لتصل الى اعتاب العاصمه
العراقيه في مؤشر الى خطوره الوضع اخلت
وزاره العدل العراقيه سجن بغداد المركزي
ابو غريب سابقا من كل نزلائه عزت الوزاره
ذلك الى وقوع السجن في منطقه ساخنه تشهد
عمليات عسكريه مسلحه كانما تتاهب حكومه
نور المالكي لامر ما واذا كانت الحكومه
تلام دوما على تدهور الاوضاع الامنيه فان
تحليلات ترجح انها ستسخر تلك الاوضاع
لصالحها تنقل صحيفه الدستور العراقيه عما
تصفها مصادر مقربه من دوائر القرار
السياسي والامني ان رئيس الوزراء العراقي
قد يلجا الى اعلان حاله الطوارئ قد يفعلها
مع بدء الانتخابات وانتهاء ولايه مجلس
النواب اما الحجه فجاز ضبط الامن ترى
الصحيفه نفسها ان نوايا المالكي جاءت بعد
بعد ان تاكد من وجود تحالفات قويه قد
تزيحه عن طموحه في نيل ولايه ثالثه صحيح
ان حلفاء الامس القريب يدخلون الاقتراع
هذه المره متفرقين فالاحزان تخوض
الانتخابات منفرده وبعضها دخل باكثر من
قائمه كما فعل المالك نفسه والتيار الصدري
وحتى المجلس الاعلى
والاكراد ومع ذلك فان دخول عمار الحكيم
مثلا في حلف مع التيار الصدري بعد نتائج
الاقتراع امر غير مستبعد ولا يستبعد
محللون ايضا ان ينضوي الاثنان في حلف
ثلاثي يضم ايضا قائمه متحدون لزعيمها
اسامه النجيفي رئيس مجلس النواب
الحالي لا شك ان المالك مدرك لثقل خصوم من
هذا العيار فهل يترك القرار للناخب
العراقي وهل ينسحب في صمت اذا
هزم موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من من
بغداد عبر سكايب الدكتوره ضمياء ربيعي عضو
ائتلاف دوله القانون ومن اربيل الشيخ فائز
الشاووش رئيس مجلس ثوار العزه والكرامه
ومن عمان الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وليد
الزبيدي وابدا من اربيل مع الشيخ فائز
الشاووش سيد فائز ماذا ماذا يعني لكم
اخلاء سجن ابو غريب من
نزلائه بكل التاكيد بعد هجوم جيش المالكي
على ابناء الانبار وعش
الانبار اخذت الثوره مجراها الطبيعي
وامتدادها حتى وصلت حزام بغداد وهذا ما
يؤثر واقلق حكومه المالكي ومن الجانب
الثاني ياخذ بها المالكي من خلال هذا
التصرف هو وزير
عدله لاستخدام الشد الطائفي لاغراض
انتخابيه في
المستقبل السؤال ايضا الذي يطرح هنا حجم
المطقه التي لا تخضع حاليا لسلطه الحكومه
في مناطق الغرب غرب
بغداد تقريبا ما يقدر من 85 الى 0% هي
ليست تحت سيطره الجي الميليشياوي او
الميليشيات المنطويه مع وبتالي هذا هو
اسباب سياسه حكومه المالك والحكومات
المتعاقبه ما بعد
2003 لان محافظات المنتفض بما فيها
الانبار هي خرجت على حقوق اقرها الدستور
الذي لم يستفتى عليه من قبل الشعب العراقي
بنسبه 60% وبالتالي خرج ابناء الشعب وفق
الدستور الذين هم امنوا به الذي يقر
التعدديه الحزبيه والفكريه والسياسيه
والشجب والاستنكار والمطالبه بالحقوق
فلذلك هدد المالك عده مرات
قائلا بان حربنا بين اتباع يزيد واتباع
الحسين ونحن نجل سيدنا الحسين وتاره يقول
سنجعل بيننا بحر بيننا بينهم بحر من الدم
وهذا تصرف اعتقد ويعتقد جميع العقلاء بانه
لا يصلح عن رئيس حكومه هو يدعي بان يحكم
مثل العراق ويؤمن بوحده العراق يتكلم
باللهجه الطائفيه مما اوصلت العراق
المناطق الاخرى الى هذا المستوى الذي كنا
لا تمناه للعراق والعراقيين دكتوره ظمياء
في ظل هذا الوضع وخروج مناطق واسعه في
الغرب عن سيطره الحكومه كيف يمكن
للانتخابات ان
تجري نعم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
شكرا لقناه
الجزيره هذا المنبر الاعلامي الذي امل ان
يكون مهنيا في هذ هذه الحلقه التي ضمت عده
اطراف وربما انا الطرف الوحيد الذي امثل
فيه دوله القانون او امثل فيه الوجهه
العراقيه الحكوميه كما
تصفون في
البدء تحدثتم في التقرير حول التحالفات
الموجوده يعنيي اعلق على التحالفات
الموجوده التي طرحتها في تعليقكم في
التقرير في التقرير هذه التحالفات ربما لا
تاتي في اللحظه الاخيره كما كما جاء في
تقريركم ربما اللحظات الاخيره من
التحالفات تضم اسماء اخرى ربما التحالف
الذي ذكرتموه حول التيار الصدري وتحالف
المواطن وحدون ربما دكتوره ضميا اسمحي
عفوا اسمحي لي هذا الموضوع هذا الموضوع
ساعود اليه في سياق هذه الحلقه وسا اسالك
عنه بدقه وبالتحديد لكن انا الان اسالك عن
الوضع الامني الذي اد
الى يعني اخلاء سجن ابو غريب من نزلائه
ووصول التوتر الى حزام العاصمه بغداد
وبالتالي نحن نقترب من الانتخابات في ظل
وضع امني متردي الى هذا
الحد سيدي الكريم نعم الذي وصفتم الذي
وصفتم بانها مدن خارجه عن السيطره هذا ليس
وصفا دقيقا ف فما يحصل من عمليات عسكريه
امتدت لاشهر في الانبار لمح الارهابيين
ومحاربه الداعشيين لا يمكن وصفه كما قال
السيد فائز بانه ثوره بل انها ثوره من
ثوره ارهاب ثوره
داعشيين العراق حاليا يتصدى لارهاب دولي
اجتمع من كل دول العالم من افغانستان ومن
الشيشان ومن دول اخرى مدفوعه الثمن ربما
مدفوعه الثمن خليجيا بدولارات الخليج يعني
التي تدفع بالارهاب ربما لدول مجاوره اخرى
تسع لان يجتمع الارهاب في العراق فايه مدن
خرجت عن السيطره الجيش العراقي البطل الذي
يصفه السيد فائز بانه جيش ميليشيات هذا
ليس وصفا حقيقيا هذا الجيش العراقي يضن كل
الاطياف العراقيه في طياته من قاده قاده
من الكرد قاده من السنه الابطال قاده من
الشيعه الابطال قاده من التركمان هذا جيش
العراق البطل الذي لا يمكن تسميته
بالميليشيات ف عزيزي ليس لدينا مدن خارجه
عن السيطره وانما لدينا مجموعات عصابات
اجراميه هي التي خرجت عن الطريق نعم طيب
ابقي معنا دكتوره ضمياء سيد وليد الزبيدي
هذا الوضع هل يمكن ان يؤثر على الانتخابات
في موعدها
المقرره العراقيون بكل اطيافهم وفئاتهم من
سياسيين
ومدنيين يتابعون الوضع العسكري باعتبار ان
السيد المالكي
اختار القوه لانهاء الاعتصامات منذ بدايه
هذا العام واستخدام القوه العسكريه تحديدا
في ذلك لذا فان الكل يتابع ميزان القوى
هناك وكيف يمكن ان يتطور لصالح اي طرف
ميزان القوى اعتقد يحسب من جانبين رئيسيين
هو اضافه للجانب المعنوي الجانب الاول هو
الخسائر البشريه بين الطرفين من المسلحين
من المجالس العسكريه والمجاميع الاخرى
التي تقاتل الجيش هناك والاجهزه الامنيه
والصحوات وايضا الخسائر بالاليات والاسلحه
اذا اخذنا عدد الخسائر في صفوف الجيش كما
يعلن وتتناقل بعض وكالات
الانباء نسبه الى ما تعلنه المجالس
العسكريه والمجاميع من الخسائر انا اعتقد
واجريت شبه احصائيه نسبه الخسائر من
المسلحين والمجالس العسكريه لا يتجاوز
الواحد بالالف من الجيش وهذا امر خطير
طبعا يؤثر معنويا على الجيش وعلى الاجهزه
الامنيه ومن معها وايضا على المنظومه
السياسيه في مختلف ارجاء العراق ما يتعلق
بالخسائر الماديه ايضا يوميا تدمر هناك
اليات كثيره دبابات و همرات وناقلات اشخاص
واسلحه بما فيها الطائرات قياسا الى قياسا
الى سلاح المسلحين اعتقد النسبه اقل من
واحد بالمليون وهذا امر خطير ايضا فيما
يتعلق بالجيش هذا كل ينعكس على الجانب
المعنوي فالجيش بتقديري ومن معه يعانون
وضع امني سيء لانه بعد ما يقرب من ثلث عام
لم تتمكن القوات العسكريه والامنيه والصح
من السيطره على سيد
وليد انا قلت بان المنظومه السياسيه
السياسيين يراقبون الميزان القوى هناك
فاذا كان ميزان القوى ما يقرب من ثلث عام
لم يتمكن الجيش والصحوات على السيطره على
مدينه صغيره بمساحه 4 ر هي الفلوجه ويزداد
انتشار المسلحين وايضا تزداد قوتهم
باستخدامهم ل الغام التي تؤثر كثيرا وايضا
سلاح القنص والهجمات الاخرى هذا الامر شهد
تطورات اخرى حصلت في الح الحرب الحاليه
وهوما يمكن ان نسميه بحرب الجسور وحرب
المياه حرب المياه الان تخشى منها الحكومه
بدليل انها اخلت سجن ابو ريب الذي يبعد
اكثر في حدود 20 الى 30 م من بغداد اي
بوابه بغداد وهناك ايضا مخاوف على معسكرات
كثيره من ان تغرق و بهذا يفضي الى ان
تنعزل اجهزه امنيه بكاملها فاما ان تهرب
من هذه المناطق الى بغداد او محيطها
وينعكس هذا الامر طبعا سلبا على ما يشعر
به السياسيون سواء في المنطقه الغربيه
وحتى في المناطق الاخرى و اكثر من يشعر
بالخوف والهلا هم الصحوات اعتقد لانه في
حال هروب القوات الامنيه سيبقون محاصرون
في مناطق الغربيه طيب ماذا بعد
هذه الاوضاع التي وصفتم وايضا ماذا عن
تحالفات المالكي في اثناء الانتخابات اذا
استمرت او جارت الانتخابات كما هو مقرر
هذا ما نناقش بعد الفاصل مشاهدينا ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد واعود الى ضيفي من
اربيل الشيخ فائز الشاووش سيد فائز هل
تعول على تعطيل الانتخابات العراقيه ام
على خساره
المالكي بكل تاكيد ان كان الوضع العراقي
يسعى اليه البعض مثلما ما
يدعون بانه سيحاولون تحسين الوضع السياسي
بالعراق انا اعتقد جميع العقلاء وهذا ما
شخصته كثير من القوى الوطنيه من الشيعيه
والسنيه والكرديه التي هي خارج المشروع
السياسي والهيئات الدينيه منذ 11 عام قالت
بان هذا المشروع السياسي لن يجدي نفعا
للعراق وللشعب العراقي والسبب او الدليل
القطعي ب نفس السياسيين اي جميع الاحزاب
السياسيه التي شاركت بعد 2003 بهذا
المشروع السياسي اقرت وتحدث الكثير منهم
قائلين بان هناك وجود الكثير من الغام في
هذا الدستور فاعتقد بالنهايه لا مصيره
للعراق وللعراقيين في ظل هذا المشروع
السياسي لان التغيير ليس بتغيير الاشكال
بل انما بتغيير هيكله المشروع اي الدستور
العراقي دكتوره ضميا اما بالنسبه للاخت
المتحدثه ساعود ساعود اليك لها نعم
تفضل لم يرى الشعب العراقي ثلاث حالات منذ
تاسيس الدوله العراقيه سنه 1921 ولغايه
2003 في جميع الانظمه السبقه
الاحتلال لم نسمع او نشاهد ثلاث حالات
منها لم نسمع اي وزير او مسؤول او مدير
عام سرقه من اموال الشعب ع دنانير ولم
نسمع نرى تدخل النظام الفارسي في الشان
العراقي كانما العراق ضيعه لبلاد فارس الا
في ظل هؤلاء السياسيين والحكومات
المتعاقبه ولن نسمع او نرى الطائفيه في
العراق في جميع الانظمه التي سبقت 2003
ابقى معي شيخ فائز ابقى معي ساعود اليك
دكتوره ضمياء هل يدور في خلد رئيس الوزراء
تاجيل الانتخابات بحجه الوضع الامني كما
تتحدث بعض بض المصادر خصوصا ان هناك من
يتحدث عن امكانيه اعلان حال طوارئ اثناء
موعد
الانتخابات اطلاقا اخي العزيز اي تاجيل
غير موجود وغير مطروح في جدول دوله رئيس
الوزراء ولا حتى المفوضيه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات لا تاجيل ولا مساومه على تاجيل
او تقديم او تاخير موعد الانتخابات
المقرره في ال 30 من نيسان المقبل اي بعد
15 يوما بالضبط وقبل ذلك بيوم او يومين
سيبدا التصويت الخاص وتصويت الخارج وفي
يوم ال 30 سيكون يوم التصويت العام لكل
ابناء الشعب العراقي بداخل العراق وخارجه
ولا وحتى بالنسبه ل ما يشع في وسائل
الاعلام حول اعلان حاله طوارئ وغير ذلك
لسنا بحاجه لدينا جيش عراقي قوي لا لا يصل
لهذا المستوى المتدني من من النسب الوهميه
يعني مع الاعتذار للاخ وال والاستاذ
العزيز السيد وليد الزبيدي يعني يفترض ان
تكون نسبه صحيحه لكنها نسب غير معقوله ففي
الوقت الذي الجيش العراقي يحقق فيه
انتصارات يعلنون فيه انها ان هناك هزائم
وفي الوقت الذي بالنسبه حتى للفلو هذا
الموضوع وموضوع تاخير ضرب المسلحين في
داخل فلوجه ومحاصرتها ياتي اسباب انسانيه
من قبل القائد العام للقوات المسلحه اننا
لا نريد ان نتسبب بايه خسائر مدنيه هنا
هنا دكتوره دكتوره ظمياء دكتوره دكتوره
ضمياء وان كان هذا الامر مختلف في مناطق
اخرى لم تكن الاسباب الانسانيه هي الحافز
لعدم حصول عمليات امنيه وفض اعتصامات لكن
لن نتحدث عن هذا الموضوع حاليا السؤال هو
هل يقلق رئيس الوزراء انفضاض حلفاء من
حوله وعدم تمكنه من الوصول الى الرئاسه
رئاسه الوزراء لمره ثالثه بعد الانتخابات
باختصار ويا اخي يا يا سيدي الكريم من قال
بانهم انفضوا من حوله من قال من قال لكم
هذه التقارير
الصحفيه كثير من التصريحات كثير من
التصريحات ما اعلنه التيار الصدري ما
اعلنه المجلس الاعلى ما اعلنه مسعود
البرزاني ما جاء
لا اح م يتحالف مع
مجددا طيب ممكن ان شاء الله سنلتقي سنلتقي
من ضمن منبركم هو نفسه وارجو ان تعدني
باننا سنلتقي عندما يتحالف ويلتف هؤلاء
الجمع الذين تقول بانهم انفضوا سيلفون حول
المالكي وحول ائتلاف دوله القانون بعد
ظهور نتائج الانتخابات لان الشعب العراقي
سيكون هو الفيصل الصناديق الاقتراع ستكون
الفيصل فسيحقق هذه الكتله كتله ائتلاف
دوله القانون والسيد المالكي شخصيا سيحقق
اعلى نسبه من الاصوات كما حصل في
الانتخابات الماضيه عند اذ سيضطر الجميع
للتحالف معه سواء تحالفوا او بكلهم او
باجزاء منهم لاننا مصممون على تشكيل حكومه
الا
فسياتي جمع من كل كتله اعدك بذلك وسنلتقي
من على منبر الجزيره واذكر حضرتك واذكر
جمهور الجزيره العزيز بان ما قلته اليوم
سيتحقق
سيتحقق مع دكت دكتوره ضميا ابقي ابقي معنا
ابقي معنا دكتوره ضميا سيد وليد واضح ان
ائتلاف دوله القانون واثق بان الجميع
سيضطر اضطرارا للتحالف مع المالك بعد فوزه
بنسبه كبيره ما
رايك انا ارى الى الانتخابات المقبله
بانها امتداد لعمليه سياسيه صنعها
الاحتلال وكل القوى الوطنيه ترفض هذه
العمليه السياسيه وانتخابات والحكومات
التي تشكلت خلال السنوات الماضيه ولكن
المقاربه التي اتحدث عنها هي العمل
العسكري الذي يح الان بعد فض الاعتصامات
السلميه من قبل الجيش المالكي هذه
العمليات تهدف الى انهاء هذه العمليه
السياسيه وبالنتائج ليس بالمقدمات هذه
اضرت كثيرا بالشعب العراقي بل دمرت الشعب
وتسعى الى تفتيته وتقسيمه عليه اذا كانت
الانتخابات تجري في موعدها فان التحالفات
لا تعني القوى المناهضه للعمليه السياسيه
والتي يمثل توجهها او جناحها العسكري الان
الثوار الذين يعملون ليل نهار على انهاء
هذه العمليه السياسيه اما القراءه
السياسيه تختلف فانا ارى في القراءه
السياسيه ان السيد المالكي اصبح يشكل عبئ
كبير على قوتين وضعته في الحكم في
الانتخابات قبل اربع سنوات وهم امريكا
وايران هذا العب اعتقد اصبح واضحا من خلال
التحالفات او المواقف الجديده للتيار
الصدري والتيار الحكيم وايضا موقف الاكراد
وسواء تمت الانتخابات وحصلت تكتلات او لم
تحصل انا اعتقد بدون تغيير الدستور واجراء
برنامج وطني عراقي شامل الامر سيتطلب
الكثير من الج وربما تستمر العمليات
المسلحه ابقى ابقى معي شيخ فائز فيما لو
حصلت الانتخابات
وخسر المالكي رئاسه الوزراء هل سيدفعهم
ذلك الى
مراجعه العمل المسلح من جديد والعوده الى
الحوار مع الحكومه الجديده اذا
شكلت انا اعتقد مثل ما بدا المالكي بحربه
على على اهالي الانبار لفضل الاعتصامات
اعتقد حتى اذا خسر المالكي باعتباره حليفا
اول لايران وريكا اعتقد من خلال سعي الى
فرض قانون
الطوارئ
لم انه سيتمسك برئاسه الوزراء ولم يعطيها
حتى اذا توسعت المعركه مع خصومه السياسيين
لكن دكتور الدكتوره ضمياء قالت انه ليس
مضطرا لاعلان حال الطوارئ ولن يحصل ذلك
ابدا طبعا لمياء تقول لانها
مليئه بعقليته بان
المالكي ايران لم تفرط بالمالكي ولا
امريكا لانه ايران وامريكا منذ البدايه
توافقت على غزو العراق واحتلال العراق وفق
مصالح مشتركه على حساب العراق ومصلحه
الشعب العراقي فلذلك اسس المشروع السياسي
على اساس طائفي واثني ومثل ما شاهدت السيد
عمار الحكيم هذا اليوم من خلال قناه
الفيحاء او العراقيه وجمهوره
يصرخ
اي كنا وياك علي كنا وياك ما ادري شنو
ويتحدث عمار الحكيم قبل فتره ويقول ان
حربنا ليس من اجل الحكم بل انما معركه
وجود ساعود ساعود ايضا اليك اذا سمح لي
الوقت
شيخا دكتوره
ضمياء يعني ربما المالكي اصبح عبءا كبيرا
على الولايات المتحده وعلى ايران وهذا ما
يعكسه مواقف الاطراف التي كانت حليفه
للملك هذا ما اشار اليه وليد الزبيدي ما
رايك نعم اولا اولا بالنسبه للسيد السيد
فائز وانا اصر باحترام ان اقول له السيد
فائز فارجو عندما يخاطبني ان يقول
الدكتوره ظمياء ولا يقول ظمياء لانني لا
اعمل عنده هذا اولا وثانيا ان لا يتبنى
افكاري ويتحدث عنها لانه ان تبنى افكاري
وقال ان بعقليه ضميا ايران وامريكا تريد
المالكي انا ايضا ساقول له ان السعوديه
وقطر تريد هؤلاء الارهابيين الداعشيين من
امثالكم بسلاحكم بارهاب بدمكم فلا يتبنى
افكاري ويتحدث بالنيابه عني لاني موجوده
هذا اولا اما بالنسبه لسؤال حضرتك حول
السيد المالكي فلا اعتقد انه يشكل عبئا بل
انه اصبح مطلبا ملحا لا كمال مشروعه
السياسي لاكمال مشروعه الانساني لاكمال
مشروعه الحكومي وبالنسبه لنا في دوله
القانون نعتقد ان الولايه الثالثه للسيد
المالكي تعد هي الحكومه الاولى الحقيقيه
له
لانال مقلا بالوزراء كان
م نعم سيد وليد باختصار شديد برايك حظوظ
المالك باتت معدومه مه
حاول امنيا وسياسيا في المرحله
المقبله هذا ما تعكسه خطابات حلفائه في
الامس في الدوره
الماضيه جميعهم الان يتحدثون بان المالكي
يعني اثر كثيرا سلبا في الحياه العراقيه
ولا اريد ادخل بالتفاصيل الان يقتربون من
فلسفه وفكر وثقافه المقاومه التي قاومت
الاحتلال ووقفت ضد الدستور والعمليه
السياسيه غالبيتهم يقولون الان يجب تعديل
الدستور والقوه الوطنيه ت انهاء الدستور
وانهاء العمليه السياس شكرا لك وليد
الزبيدي فائز الشوش وضميه الربيعي شكرا
جزيلا لكم وشكرا للمتابعه مشاهدينا والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه